It took us a while here and I think we
spent a month trying to get through
and this last attempt was in the
truck
in which I had the accident, I
remember that we got to where we
were going to be picked up at 2 in the afternoon,
but I  I think that they came
moving us around 2 in the morning or
3 in the morning. I only remember that
I heard that they said that the pipe
was already there, they had already thrown it away and that was when
the trucks started and passed
but the first truck got stuck.
we got out and pushed
her to help her pass the
same thing with ours
but since a van broke down
now I think three trucks
will pass
but I think one van broke
down and when ours passed it
was the second  When I turned around and saw a
lot of people running towards our
truck,
I imagine that it must have been the
need to be able to go
through, that's why
they clung to getting into our
truck, well, before they  When we got to the wall
, they divided us into the three trucks, there
were about 19 or 20 of us in each truck,
but since they knocked down the wall, as
I'm telling you, I think a truck broke
down.
About 25 of us who
were in the truck were very
tight and what I remember was
when I asked my friend who
was next to me how he felt and he
told me that it was very tight
and I encouraged him to choose which  It will hold
that God was going to let us
get safely to where the driver
took us
but I only remember up to that point and I already
remembered again but since I was in the
hospital from there and I don't
remember very well about my accident.  But
I imagine that the truck
was going a little fast.
I woke up around Thursday,
Wednesday night, I heard that my mother was going to
come here with me, but on Thursday my
son, my mother, told me more about how
the accident happened.  but I did not
remember anything because I am very
grateful to God that he has given me
another chance in this life,
yes I feel very happy that he
was able to survive that accident
, my mother had already practiced it on her,
I came  to come to work
to support my brother in his
study and more than anything to get her out of
work, yes, the truth is that she did, they
were very kind to me at the
hospital,
although there were many who did not understand Spanish very
well, but they were very  kind